So.
Listen.
Stop copying me.
STOP COPYING ME!
I am vengeance.
I
What?
I’m vengeance.
All right,
Vengeance.
You're f#ckin fired.
What?
No, I’m your replacement.
No, you're not.
I’m gonna have to sight the case
of aint broke
v don't fix.
Seriously,
I don’t even know why
you're here.
What’s the difference?
I'm”THE” Batman.
You're Batman.
Okay.
I don't mean to be
Sean Parker here,
but you can drop the “THE”
nobody wants to go to
“THE” Facebook
and nobody's afraid of
“THE” Batman
I don’t wanna trigger you, but uh
you’re the dinosaur.
Look at that suit.
So, 2005.
Okay,
What's so great
about your suit?
How?
How is this
an improvement
over this?
Are you kidding me?
Use your eyeballs.
Cowl goes up.
The cowl goes up.
Okay yeah. No, I.
I was just praying
I hadn’t heard you,
but I did.
So you have
a turtle neck.
So the chilly
rain doesn't land
on the back
of your head.
I know you’re goofin around right now
but yeah,
When it's raining
pretty hard,
the cowl up version
is better than the
cowl down version.
Okay.
Keeps my neck warm.
Cause this is the rainy season, man.
Gotham is...
WET.
Sorry, but
what’s up with that voice?
What?
This voice?
Yeah.
This voice rules.
That voice sucks.
It rules.
It sucks.
Yours drools.
Yours is too gravelly.
Yours isn’t even masked.
It’s just your regular
Bruce Wayne voice
lowered.
Yeah, I want people to lean in
so I can pop em
right in the mouth.
You sound like
you’re getting winded.
Pulling the
foil off
of a single
serving yogurt.
Well,
I actually am
plant based,
so I don't
eat yogurt.
So.
Yeah,
a lot of berries.
Nuts.
Actually, Alfred
makes a little
mild avocado dip
for me
every morning.
Are you
even wearing black
eye makeup
or are you just
low iron?
Oh, ha ha ha.
You need to eat some
f#ckin meat.
You’re gonna need those calories
When you fight
hardened criminals.
A.)
There are multiple ways to get protein
you don't need to slaughter
and take the life of an animal
to get it.
B.)
I don’t do much fighting.
What?
I get to the crime scene
after it's happened.
I poke my nose around,
take some notes,
talk to the cops.
Wait.
You just
walk around like a regular cop?
Yeah.
They like havin me around.
Jesus.
F#ck.
Look.
Man, you got a face it.
I'm cool.
I'm edgy.
Okay?
I'm Kurt Cobain.
Yeah,
cause you're dead to me.
I think I’ve made my point.
I'm the winner.
You're the wiener.
I’m about to make my point.
August 6th,
Sometimes
life hurts.
But then
the wounds
scar over
and you’re then mainly just scars.
Sorry, are you journaling
at me?
Scars are
like muscles
on the outside
of your body.
And they make
you strong
against dicks
who don’t understand
how cool you are.
My scars make me
so strong.
They make me
stronger than
metal.
Metal, wind...
We deserve better than this.
You know what, I'll finish this later.
Fine.
You ok buddy?
Sometimes
that kind of stuff
takes a lot outta me.
Drops my
blood sugar levels.
Yeah.
I forgot to bring a snack.
Do you have any food?
Okay,
so vengeance
is asking me
if I have any food?
You don’t have
anything here?
I, I do have
some crackers.
Rice or wheat?
It's wheat.
I’m gluten free.
Sh#t.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Woah.
Are you okay?
Bruce?
BRUCE!?
Oh,
I’m cool man, I’m cool.
I’m cool.
But, gluten
you can't handle.
Nobody touch me.
Hey,
You do this?
What is that?
Adrenaline.
Straight from a bull’s
cawk.
No, I don't
I don’t inject myself
with bull d*ck.
Every night, before I go out,
i’m in the bat car.
Just,
crankin
SHOT AFTER SHOT!
You got to go, man.
This feels like
an NA situation.
You need help.
The type of help that
a popped up collar can’t give you.